[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery ant-man of the wasp
review I will explain where it falls in
the timeline without talking too much
about spoilers but it was totally a
breath of fresh air now that the dust
has settled from infinity war so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos there's also a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this so
the film itself mostly focuses on
developing the wasp character pretty
clear to say that Kevin Feige said that
the thing that he was most excited about
for this film was the wasp character
talking mostly about hopes character but
they've had this Avengers number one
blow-up picture in the Marvel Studios
offices for a long long time but it's
been a long time since we've had the
actual Avengers movie but they haven't
been able to do all the characters from
Avengers number one no ant-man and no
wasp for a long time so when it came
time to do the movie Kevin Feige said he
was most excited to actually fulfill the
promise of Avengers number one because
now we finally have that really badass
version of the wasp and you'll come out
of the movie wondering why the hell
haven't they done the wasp before now
and mostly that's because they hadn't
done ant-man yet they changed the Hank
Pym character and even though they do
change a couple things from the comics
Marvel movies in general are still
informed by what happened in the comics
so one thing at a time you do ant-man
you do Hank Pym then you introduce the
new versions of the characters so
finally we get our wasp and Evangeline
Lilly killed it I'll say you know I
liked her better in this movie than I
did in the first ant-man movie they gave
you a bit of a taste of that character
so you have an idea of how badass she is
but you never actually get to see her in
a costume until now on top of that
there's this big generational theme to
the story you have parents and children
fathers and daughters because you have
this hope Hank relationship from the
first film that carries over but now you
also have Janet Van Dyne s character
they find a way to weave that theme in
with the villain Hannah John K man's
ghost character but to be clear there
isn't a real fan OHS type Marvel villain
in this film the way that Thanos was the
villain of infinity war or Obadiah Stane
was the villain of the first Iron Man
film there's his new breed of Marvel
characters that they're introducing in
their films really good
villains kill monger lochia really good
examples of that loki was almost an
aberration from phase one like one of
the very few really awesome villain
characters but you get to Black Panther
and Michael B Jordan just absolutely
kills it and Jon came in also an amazing
performance as what you would call the
villain of the film she's more of the
antagonist not so much the villain but
you do understand her perspective and
even though obviously the film's very
different from Black Panther she is a
very kill monger type character somebody
with a big ax to grind that does go off
the rails but she's not like a mustache
twirling villain that's only in it for
money or some stupid motivation she does
have a really good arc and a really good
motivation for wanting things from the
main characters that put them at odds so
charting it in the timeline I think it's
not a spoiler to say that this movie
takes place before the snap sure so
that's why you're seeing all this Civil
War stuff that's referenced in all the
trailers hope tells ant-man why didn't
you call me when Captain America called
you I could have prevented you from
getting caught after Civil War you
wouldn't be under house arrest now so
there's this period of time that they're
playing with before the snap sure and
even though the plot of the movie is
meant to be very self-contained like you
can go into this movie not really
knowing anything about infinity war I
don't know anybody that's gonna see this
though that has not just seen infinity
war but there are a couple big moments
that tie it to what just happened and
what's happening in Avengers 4 mostly
pushing you into Avengers 4 so yes there
are two post-credit scenes
make sure you stay through the entire
end credits I would say they were about
95 percent of what I expected Marvel
post-credit scenes nowadays are usually
a mixture of really funny haha moments
and then moments that push you into the
plot of the next film little bit of like
thor ragnarok post-credit scenes like
one funny moment with the characters and
then one moment tying you to the events
of what's happening during the Avengers
films if you haven't been following the
press tour Laurence Fishburne and
Michael Douglas are on fire boran's
Fishburne himself he plays Goliath in
the movie and they do a really good job
with his character not quite what I
expected them to do with the character
but he has a bit of a Steve Jobs Bill
Gates relationship with Hank Pym
they have a fun way of invoking Marvel
Comics history where you know there was
a period in the comics where Goliath
became the new giant man of the Avengers
but he called himself Goliath so within
the context of the movie he and Hank
used to work together so they have a fun
relationship during the movie in
present-day because now they're both
kind of grumpy old men but hank was his
old mentor so the movie itself does
trade a lot on the mistakes of Hank Pym
in the past like if you remember during
the first ant-man movie you got the
flashback so you got a little taste for
what Hank Pym was like when he was
younger his mistrust of other people the
temper that he had some of the big
character twists and turns trade on
mistakes that Hank made in the past so
they have a really cool way of filling
in a lot of Marvel MCU backstory like
all this stuff was happening during this
period in time that we haven't seen yet
so like now Michael Douglas has been
saying I totally want to come back and
do a younger version of my character in
a future Marvel film who knows that they
would do that because it is kind of
expensive to do that CG 2d Age people I
would love to see more of young Michelle
Pfeiffer because just like wasp in this
movie hope Van Dyne is a total badass
Michelle Pfeiffer is also a total badass
as the original version of the wasp so
if you're a longtime Janet fan from the
comics I feel like they do a good job of
doing her honor but you do have to
remember the characters ages in present
day like hope in Scott are the main
versions of the characters now but they
do have a lot of classic Avengers
moments even though technically in the
MCU Nick Fury is the person who created
the Avengers initiative Michael Pena was
awesome he stole most of the scenes that
he was in just like he did during the
first ant-man film pretty much that
entire crew comes back from the first
ant-man film they have this funny
business called ex-con Kevin Feige was
wearing their hat at the ant-man in the
wasp premiere so everybody was wondering
if he was wearing that as a sort of wink
at the x-men deal that's about to go
through at Disney but that is the name
of their business but I also think it's
a bit of a double entendre like yeah
haha x-men stuff coming in the future if
you're a big justified fan Walton
Goggins does an amazing job during the
film not exactly what I expected from
his character but he's playing Sonny
birch another person from the comics
I'll talk a little bit more about that
stuff when I get to my Easter Egg video
the music was
great totally the film was just much
lighter as the trailers have implied I
was also pleasantly surprised that there
weren't any big fake trailer moments
that we've thought that we were going to
be getting from now on like you saw all
the money that Marvel spent on that fake
Hulk and the infinity war trailer and
you just wonder if they're gonna be
doing this from now on but I guess
that's a case-by-case basis maybe just
for the Avengers films so overall film
definitely the breath of fresh air that
everybody is talking about after
infinity war good palate cleanser but
also works really well as a big summer
blockbuster film I wouldn't say that
it's absolutely necessary that you watch
it before Avengers 4 but there are a
couple of big moments and concepts that
they introduce that will be critical to
the plot of Avengers 4 so yes it is
important to watch it don't wait til
later this year when it hits blu-ray so
what will happen is is just like I do
for a normal Marvel films as I'll do
post-credit scenes Easter eggs spoiler
review all that stuff later this week
after people have a chance to see the
movie be sure to go see it once you do
let me know in the comments what you
thought of it I'm gonna wait to rank
this film on my list of favorite Marvel
films till I have a chance to see it one
or two more time so we'll do that when I
do my spoiler review or my easter egg
video congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Ironhide please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll name a new winner when I
post new Marvel but click here to learn
about Kevin Feige teasing Young Avengers
during phase 4 and click here for that
Avengers for Comic Con panel thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you